the three of us are here because we know
what a great feeling it is to win an
Academy Award for directing yeah it was
the greatest auditor that I've ever
received hey guys I never won an Academy
Award so why are you here uh I don't
know I got nominated a couple of times
well anyway the two of us know what a
great honor it will be for one of the
five nominees well I I just want to say
it's much better to give than receive no
it's not and here are the nominees for
Best Director for Babel alejandro
gonzalez
for the departed Marty Scorsese
four letters from iwo jima Clint
Eastwood
for the Queen Steven fears
and for United 93 Paul Greengrass spread
up
and the Oscar goes to Martin Scorsese
Martin Scorsese's road to the Oscars
began in 1956 after he entered the
seminary and then opted to channel his
passions into film
thank you thank you Rick thank you
thank you
thank you thank you thank you please
please thank you thank you could you
double check the envelope rings hi thank
you so mean I'm overwhelmed with this
honor with the Academy and also the
honor of being presented by my old old
friends we go back 37 years I'm so moved
and so moved like I've got to thank
Warner Brothers Alan horn and Dan and
and Jeff and I've got to thank our
producers Brad Graham Graham King and
Mack Brown and my old friend Joe Reedy
for working for 20 years and Rick Ewan
and John listen Chris Donnelly and Ari
Emanuel and that crazy script by Bill
Monaghan got me in all this trouble in
the first place and Andrew laws original
film from Hong Kong the wonderful Asian
cinema and Michael Ball House on camera
and Howard shores wonderful score and my
old good friend Thelma Schoonmaker um
Ellen Lewis for her casting and so much
of this belongs to the cast I can't tell
you Jack Nicholson for his courage and
his inspiration Leo DiCaprio six and a
half years work we've done together
I hope another 12 mother 15 Mark
Wahlberg Matt Damon Alec Baldwin Ray
Winstone and Vera Farmiga and Marty
Sheen I just want to say too that so
many people over the years have been
wishing this for me so strangers you
know I go I went walk in the street
people say something to me are going to
doctor's office are going to whatever
elevators people saying I wish you
should win no should win I go for an
x-rays they should win one and I'm
saying thank you and then the lots of
friends friends a mine over the years
and friends over here tonight or wishing
this for me and my family I thank you
this is for you and I also want to thank
and I want to thank my daughter Kathy is
here to know who worked on the film and
domenica and my wife Helen and our
little Francesco who's seven years old
who's watching right now
Francesca stare for another 10 minutes
but then jump up and down to make a lot
of noise at the hotel okay I'll see in
the morning thank you